you mentioned the United States uh
what's the role of the United States
in the struggle that you've been
describing what's the positive what's
the negative
the role is perpetuating what's
happening honey
it's all a negative role to be honest
with the money with power yeah it's like
the 3.8 billion in military aid every
year
it's the standing ovation Israel is the
largest recipient of U.S foreign AIDS
since World War II to date United States
has provided Israel 150 billion dollars
as you said is providing currently 3.8
billion every year
um
that a lot of people raised the question
of what's the interest of tax paying
American citizens in this kind of yeah
zero interest foreign aid zero interest
I don't think Americans I think
Americans a lot of Americans are
concerned with health care a lot of
Americans are concerned with clean water
in Flint I don't think they are
concerned with funding apartheid in
another country and I think it's a
disturbing phenomenon that although
public opinion in the United States is
Shifting I would argue
drastically about Palestine
people in Washington are yet to catch up
it was only I think nine Congress people
who boycotted herzog's speech
um in Congress yesterday and he received
Standing Ovation after Standing Ovation
after Standing Ovation after sending
Ovation and I wonder
um if the everyday American
is concerned that many of their
politicians are Israel first politicians
are politicians who care more about
maintaining a relationship with the
Israeli regime that they care about
their own districts